最後にブッダの道っていうのは驚くほどシンプルです
合成された現象ではなく
元素のレベルで観察する
信仰 感情 好み 主観を捨てて客観的に見るという
だから別に何もやることないんです
信仰もいらんし 勉強も要りませんし
ただ客観的に生きるということはどういうことかと見ればいい
誰でも生きているんだからできないわけないでしょ
生きることは何やと学ぶためには
もうアメリカの大学卒にしなきゃダメですよというのはおかしいでしょ
誰でも生きてるんだから
だから何も言いません
日常の生き方ですよ ちょっと 2つに分けます
日常生活と仏道という
ブッダの教えに基づいた日常の生き方
心を育てる 清らかにする修行と 2つに分けて考えられる
しかし 完全に離れたものではなく
幸福 安らぎ 雪の 1本の線路なんです
で 再計でやったっても
結局は涅槃に達するまで道はちゃんとできています
筋はギリギリまで基本に戻って生きることです
だから仏道っていうのは
ただギリギリまで基本に戻って生きること
それなら簡単ですよ 例えば基本に戻るというのは原始時代に戻ることじゃないんです
妄想から解放されるだけなんです
まあわけなから必ずしも人間はネックレスつけなくちゃいけないんだよというのはちょっとおかしいし
私は誰よりも豪華なネックレスをつけなくちゃいけないんだよ
メッターつけるべきではなくて
その必要があるかないか
だからそういうぐらいの順番なんです
日常生活についてはね
中部経典の 31 番目シガールスッテン
正しい在家生活を簡単に完璧にまとめてあります
もしかすると本が出ると思います
あの 在家の人はどう生きるべきかということを
だいたい若い人が相手なんですけども
短い経典 ちょっと短い短くもないんですけど
全部何も残る漏らすことなく語っています
そこで一つだけ例を紹介します
社会との関係 社会というと大げさでしょ？曖昧でしょ
社会って何とわからなくなっちゃう
人は六方囲まれているように
6種類の社会関係をとる
お釈迦様はいうのは六方あるでしょ
あんた六方から逃げられないでしょ
東西南北上下という そういうふうに社会も 6種類になる
そちらに関係を持ちなさい
正しい それで六方というのは
1両親  2 師匠 目上の人
3 友人  4 家族  5 部下雇っている人々
6 宗教指導者です 人間にはその 3つが
それで終わり 社会は そこで自分の役割は総合的に
例えば親という社会がある
そこで自分がその時子ども
息子として 子どもとしてどう対応すればいいかと
その場合はこれこれするんだよと
一つ一つしてたら 親が子供に一つずつする
子供は親に 5つの項目を
義務を果たすを覚える
それで自分には子供とか奥さんがいるでしょ
そうなってくると 自分の子供に親
親 親が自分にやった意思をやってあげればいい
で 友達の場合 友達がいると同じレベルの人々でしょ
それ以外は社会がないんだって言わないんだけど
社会とはどんな程度なんです
国はどうしようか 王様のことどうしようかと
それは関係ないんです
例えば家来として仕事をしているならば
王様にどう対応する？その場合
王様じゃなくて自分を雇われている人でしょ
だから一人のお釈迦様の教えはどちらにも当てはまります
人間社会というのは 6つに分けちゃえば
仕事も義務も 6種類になるんです
で それ一つの項目だけで
それから友人とは何せやと
悪友はなんせやと 収入はどうするのかと
それから自分の性格はどうするのかって
そこで項目全部終わります
自分の人間性格としては
嘘を言わないで 酒に溺れないでとか
いくつか守る それから性格的には誘惑されないという
怖いんだから やっぱり悪いんだけど
あいつは怖いんだからやるとかでやめなさい
そういう風な判断したりする場合はしっかりしないと
それがそれがあって それは性格的なところで
それから収入をどうするのかということがあって
それから収入の無駄遣いについて 4つ
4つの項目があって で
悪友の 4つと善友の 4つで
はい 終わりと 全部人間の人生全部まとめて
こんな短い状態になる
でっかいテキストでもないんです
しかし それ説明するとバカでかいテキストになりますけど
お釈迦様の語り方っていうのはすごいんです
それが在家の方々にはよく戒律ということを教えているんですね
それ そんなに難しい戒律ではないんですよ
嘘をつかないで 生命を殺さないぐらいの ５つですけど
この人々は精神的に混乱しているから
底知れない欲や希望があるから
簡単に周りの影響を受けるから
どう生きれば良いかもわからないまま
無知のまま生きているのです
世界の人間を見てみると
そんな状態 頭混乱しているんですよ
物事をはっきり判断しない
いわゆる頭整理整頓していないんです
そうなってくると みるみるもの
あれも欲しい これも欲しいとなっちゃうんです
欲しくないのに テレビ宣伝見ると欲しくなっちゃうんです
必要でもないのに欲しいと思ったりする
それで自分が何のために生きているのかとかね
あれこれ欲しくなったっても
収入はそう簡単に増えるわけじゃないでしょうし
だからあれが欲しいなのに
この給料では 20年も貯めておかないと買えないんだよということになったりする
しょうがない それでも分割払い買ってやるそうです
カードローンで買うそうとか
それでひどい目にあうでしょう
だから自分で人生管理コントロールできない人間ばっかりなんです
私は不思議に思うのは
なんでこのローンを取るんですか？どこを見てもローン会社の宣伝ばっかりでしょうし
あれってもうやってはいけないんですよ
でもどうしようもない時はありますけど
例えば突然誰か病気になったとか
お金がそんな時なかったとかね
でもそんな時さえもなんとかなるし
なんで軽々とローンを借金して
それで別なところから借金して
それ払って これって人間でしょうかと言いたいぐらい
お金がなかったらなかったでいいんじゃないですか
だから頭いいっていうのは
ある収入でちゃんと頭使って間に合うこと
それが生きる なんて言いますかね
生きがいなんです 10万円も必要
10万円必要っていうのはもう無知なんですよ
ではなくて 5万円しかない
これでどうやってこれをやるのかという
考えて10万円のことをできるんですよ
この場合は これこれっていうのは買う必要はないんですよ
で あの人持ってますから
ちょっと借りてもらいましょうとかね
あ この人はこれがありますからね
ちょっとお願いしましょうとかね
そういうふうなことで物事はする
とにかく それが知恵ということで
そうやってくると もう生きがいというものがありますよ
やっぱり 10万円 5万円しかない
はい 電話かけて5万 電話じゃなくて
なんか今どこでもローンできますからね
はい こうやりして5万借りましょうとか
それはもう完全に若者の生き方なんです
それは仏教的な生き方じゃない
なんとか頭を働かさない
それで人は頭混乱してるんですよ
小学生の子供たちも頭がもうものすごい激しく混乱してる
だから何しているのか自分でもわからない
みんなもう気持ち悪いほど人がやることだけやる
それだけの人間なんです
人がやってもやらなくても
自分がやりたいことをやればいいし
やりたくないことをやめればいい
そんな判断能力はないんです
それでこの戒律っていうのは必要になるんです
人生はね 解けないほど複雑になっています
頭混乱しているんだから
戒律は心の混乱をなくして
シン・・・シンプルなライフをもたらすんですね
戒律っていうのは もう人生を整理整頓してくれます
みんなやるんだからやるんじゃなくて
やるべきことをやって
やっちゃいけないことをやめるとはっきりしたプログラムなんです
そうなってくると 直接頭が整理整頓されます
心が落ち着く それで人生はもう問題ない
それから芯の強い人間になります
なぜ芯が強くなるかというと
世間っていうのはものすごくダメな人間ばっかりでしょ
その世間で生きてるんだから
自分がしっかりとプログラムがあって生きているということで
もう芯が強いんです あれこれと悩んだりすることがなくなるんだ
そういうわけでお釈迦様は
そのために必要な具体的な戒律を項目いくつか語ってはいるんです
それから苦労した 苦労しない生き方
金があっても 友人 家族
権力などがあっても 人生は楽
幸福とは生きれません
あれもこれも欲しいと思う人生はいつでも乾いているのです
あれも欲しい これも欲しいという人生だったらね
心はない ない 足らないとつぶやいています
あれが欲しいなと思うと
心の中でない ない ないことなんですよ
これ 精神的に悪いんです
暗い 希望をたくさんあるということは
すごく暗いということなんです
財産などの準備は基準は欲しいではなく
必要か否かだけです シンプルです
人生は 仏教は高価なカバンを使うなよとか
全然そんなこと言わないんです
高価な料理食べるなよとか
そんなことはいちいち決めません
その代わりに あなたにとって欲しいではなく必要
欲しいだったらダメ バツ必要だったらもうしょうがない
必要だからどんとやります
はっきり言えば 欲しいものには千円も使ってはいけないんです
必要なものがあったら
100 万でも必要ですから
払って買いなさい すぐ
だから 100万円で買い物する人はそれでね
あれいいな 欲しいなと
いくら？ 1,000円
やっぱり買いたい 買わない
それは 100万円の買い物しているも同然
で 買わない それが仏教だから
私も時々店で買い物をすると
それほど必要でないものを買おうとした場合は
やっぱりお金もったいないと思いますよ
それ高いものじゃない
1,000円とかもう 800円とか
ある人に 800円なんですけど
あんた人殺しでしょう？と言ったんです
それこそ人殺し値段で
こんなくだらんガラクタにとか
でも その日で私は 5万
6万ぐらいの買い物しているんです
それで 800円にいろいろ決着をつける
それが私にとってはもう必要ではないものを買わなかったんです
だからどうしてもあのレストランでご飯食べなくちゃじゃないんです
だからよく覚えててください
それで人生は全部整理整頓します
必要ならすぐ行動する
欲しいなら遠慮しておく
欲しい欲しいっていうことは必要じゃないんです
欲しいプラス必要だったらもう話ですね
欲しいで必要しだったらもう買うのは当たり前ですから
なるのは当たり前ですから
次は心の問題でね 心清らかにする道を歩まなくちゃいけないんですね
これ大胆な大げさなことではないんですよ
心清らかにするということはすごいシンプルです
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法というデータが増えるんです
目に耳に鼻にデータが増えますよ
周りから それだけの生き方でしょ
目があるんだから いろんなものを見ている
耳があるんだから 音が耳に触れる
舌があるんだから味を感じる
体があるんだからいろんな感触を感じる
なんでシンプルにしないんですか？人生は
それが科学的な事実でしょう
生きると言ったって 頭でいろんなことを考える
持つしかないんです ロボットと同じなんです
複数のファンクションをつけてるんです
そこでそれを不注意で認識
判断する 目に入るデータは何も躊躇もなく馬鹿みたく見ている
これが危ない 操縦桿を握ってないんです
見れたい放題というかね
で 判断しますね あれってすごい面白い
すごい美しいとか それかあれはすごく醜いんですよとか
不注意で判断した時点で心が汚れるんです
汚れて悪を犯したりする
悪思考で話すと悪口 行動すると悪行為です
それで我々は目耳鼻を不注意で放っておく
放し飼い だから耳に何が入ったっても
もう全然管理しません
警備入れてないんです
セキュリティ入れてないんです
だから耳からどれぐらい心が汚れるか知ったものじゃない
恐ろしいですよ だって喋って喋ってどんな悪いことでもできますから
喋るだけに この悪政治家とかよくやってるでしょう
独裁者とか 喋るとみんな聞いて
大勢みんな集めてひどいことをやる
だから警備つけてないんだから
目に耳に鼻に口に心が汚れる
それで思考が汚れるんですよ
思考が汚れたら その人何やったってもダメなんです
だって考えで喋る 考えて行動するんだから
考えがアウトだったら最後はアウトになる
だから善悪判断というのはとても心配
人にできますよ 悪は誰が作ったのかとかね
なんで生命に悪が入ったんです？そんなもう何の意味もない質問なんです
科学的に見れば 原始的な神はガードしてないだけ
だから何でもボケーッと見るんじゃなくて
ちょこっと観察してた方がいいんです
入る音は何でもボケーッと入れておくんじゃなくてね
心に何でも流れるように放っておくことは良くないんです
だから簡単な方はすごいシンプル
妄想をやめればいい 非論理的な
非現実的な 非生産的な
無意味な妄想をやめる
たちまち人生は幸福になるわかる
すべての人間の問題っていうのは
この妄想から来る 怒りも嫉妬も憎しみも落ち込みも舞い上がりも精神病気も人殺しも銃の乱射事件も
強盗も何でもかんでも妄想の結果なんですよ
妄想は自分勝手にやるんだから
それは簡単にやめられますよ
論理的に考える 生産的に物事を考える
能力が向上する ストレスがなくなる
ストレスも妄想から生まれるんです
論理的に生産的に考える
そんなにたくさん考える必要もなくなっちゃうし
ちょこっと考えちゃっても楽しいし
それで生産的に考えるということは
能力がいっぱいあるっていうことなんです
だから人間 能力はどうしよう
能力が能力がないと何で泣くのかって
みんなに能力あるんです
能力っていうのは大胆なことじゃないんで
妄想やめれば能力なんです
ただ ものすごい臭い重いゴミで心を塞いで潰してるだけ
もうゴミを捨てちれば妄想という
それで時間の余裕がありますよ
みんな時間がない 時間がないと泣いてるでしょ
それは妄想に時間がかかるんだから
時間がないっていうことは物理的でなければいけません
例えば私にはもう 5時半で他の予定があるとすると
新宿でちょっと時間がないということでなるでしょう
これは物理的なもの それ以外は時間がないっていうのはそれなくなりますよ
この余裕が現れるとなおさら修行できます
まあただの人間で生きてるんじゃなくて
人間の世界を超えてやると
それでその人にだけ特別なことできます
ただちょっと瞑想してみるだけ
それからちょっと論理的にですね
命って何なのかと 神しか知らない人間が
太刀打ちできないすることところではないなどなど
ふざけたことを言うのは
命とは何かと具体的に知らないからなんです
命には何ともすることはいけませんとかね
アメリカでは禁止しちゃったんですね
遺伝子研究ではなくて
何とか何とかあの研究というものとかね
これはキリスト教の道徳に反するんだと
キリスト教はもともと道徳はないんですけど
で まあいろいろ それって命は何やらわからない馬鹿な人々が平気で無責任で喋るだけ
命は生きているんだから
はっきりした科学的な答えがあるはずなんです
これまたとても心配です
肉体にある感覚が命心ですよ
肉体っていうのは肉体があって
感覚があるでしょ この感覚が心なんです
だからテーブルには...テーブルは命ではありません
感覚がないんです 耳は命です
感覚があるんです 感覚で見たり聞いたりするだけ
物質の感覚も因縁により生じる消える
だから私の聴覚は音が触れるたびに現れる
音がなかったらない だから感覚永遠不滅じゃないんです
見えるということは 見えるものがある時だけ見える
見えるものがなくなっちゃうと見えない
それで見えるものによって視覚が変わるんです
だから 恐ろしい 恐ろしいスピードで感覚が変化していくんです
感覚が心なんです だから心っていうのは
命というものは恐ろしいスピードで変化して変化していくのです
それで物質はどうでしょう
それは科学者に聞いたってわかるでしょう
物質も止まらないんです
ずっと変化しているんです
その一箇所で合成するだけのこと
対数変化する 動いている
だから命ってそんな程度のこと
観察で悟り 瞬間的に起こる物質
肉体の変化と感覚の変化を観察していると
生命に対して 自分の命に対して
今まであった無知 恐れ
迷信 概念 価値観 観念 信仰などは跡形もなくなる
今までなんと馬鹿なことを考えて生きてきたのか
ただ生きるということは実験してみるんです
どういうことか それでいつでも生きているんだから
実体のない無常であることを発見して悟りに達する
ああ 魂みたいな何も実体はないんだ
ただプロセス プロセス
プロセス 耳のプロセス
目のプロセス 舌のプロセスとかね
6つのプロセスがこちらで合わす
もう何て言いますか 合流してる
全部流れてできているんです
これか それで心はもうすごい安らぎを得られる
一回発見したら発見でまだわからなくなったということはありえないんです
それで悟りに達するんです
次に道場と書いてある
修行に必要なのは自分の体だけです
道場とかではなくて 修行にはやっぱり自分の体が必要なんですね
だから修行できないといえば
もう体がないということですね
誰かに盗まれたとか 時間
時間がないとよく言うでしょう
普通に生活する時間が修行の時間なんです
修行に時間がないということは
普通に生きてないということですよ
寝たり起きたり ご飯食べたりしてないみたい
ブッダからそう簡単には逃げられません
ブッダはあくまでも馬鹿はあなただよとハッキリするんです
失敗はあなたをするんであり
ブッダじゃないんだよと
だから修行にはいろいろ必要だ
体が何か盗まれたらできません
時間 まあ生きている時間があればね
修行はできます 歩く 座る
横になる 話す 見る 聞く
食べる 服を着るなどの行為を観察する
例えば今の服を変えると体が変わるでしょうに
その気分も変わるで その服を変えるだけでも
それでお風呂に入る また別な人間になってるんです
それでパジャマを着て
また別な人間になっている
布団に入ったらまた別な人間と
みるみるうちに自分が変わっていくんでしょう
それで寝た人間じゃないでしょ
起きる場合は全く別格の人間でしょ
それは覚えておいてください
寝る時の気分と起きる時の気分と
いかに違う人間かと みるみるうちに
早いスピードで変わっていく
それだけで瞑想です メッカに行くことも
八十八ヶ所の巡礼も滝行も修行道具や服もいらないんです
何も特別なことじゃない
愚か者がシンプルだから
そんなシンプルな修行ですけど
あまりにもシンプルすぎて
大体私の経験 見たい経験から誰も真剣にやらないんですね
なんか変に何か変な顔で見るんですね
なんか私はすごい世の中で稀な愚か者やみたいな感じです
これだけのことだから
やってごらんって言ったらやりませんね
だってよく言うのはちょっと 1 分でいいんだから
体ちょっと止めてくださいと
はい わかりました そうですね
私は馬鹿だと思ってるから止めてくださいって言ったら
私は止めることを意味しますけどね
だから人に指を指す前にね
自分のことを気にした方がいいんです
だからこの心配だから
なんかくだらん神話物語
アラビンの乱暴な物語ばっかり信じているんだから
なんかこのロマンスがないみたいです
ロマンスで苦しんできたんだ
来たんだから嘘ばっかしの世界
そんなロマンスでいいけど
私はもう三菱会社の社長だとか思っちゃえばロマンスでしょ
でもバイトパート社員かもしれませんだけど
実際は そんなのどうでもなんだからね
愚者は神秘が必要 ミステリーが必要
神話や物語が必要 魔法
奇跡 神の計らい 運命 天命なども必要ですね
愚者は幻覚幻想を楽しむが
知者は現実を経験する
だから愚者は幻想 幻覚を楽しみたいんですね
神の声を聞きたいとか
生きることは単純シンプルだと認めたくないから
瞑想しても妄想になるんですね
日常で経験できないより大きい幻覚を期待するから
無知無明を破れなくなる
瞑想したっても 何かすごい大胆な
このもう何か神が現れてきて
観音が現れてきて なんとかやると
真言密教みたいに チベット密教では
悟る時は大日如来か如来が出てきて
冠を持ってきて自分の頭にかぶせてくれるんだ
あるチベットの有名なお坊さんがそうやって説法するんです
で それにそのお坊さんが説法して
でも誰もそういう経験ないんだけど
正直に言います そんなことを言ったって
だったらね かわいそうですよ
そういう気分がある限りは
瞑想したっても無知は破れません
それを破ることが悟りの世界なんです
悟り 解脱 最終的な幸福は今ここにあるのに
水平線の水平線 水平線の向こう側を見ているんです
...こちらなんです
あちら向こうですかねと
智者は当たり前に戻る
毛糸の玉をほどけることは猫にできません
結べるだけでしょう だから人生ぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ複雑しているのは
もう猫と毛糸の玉と同じ話ですよ
愚者っていうことなんです
これ大変だ あれ大変 例えば新しい法律なんか作ろうと思ったら
日本の政府はどういうほど苦労するのか
正真正銘の まあそこを言わない
我々近視点は政治的な発言
発言してはいけないと
専門家だったらさっさとまあこうします
ああしますと決めればいいでしょう
人間はもう国民はもう年金払うと
それで記録するだけでしょうに
それができないんだ それで私たちにいろんなことを言うんだからね
もうなんか言いたいんです
全てを結べる生き方は無知の証拠なんです
智者は ん？あ 結れた人生を解くんです
だから糸が向こうに待っても
ちゃんとこれとこれと一本にするんです
はい これです あのセーターとかね
ありません 毛糸であれすっごいいろんな模様あったっても
1本ずっと引いたら全部解けるでしょう
だって愚者に任せたると
逆の方向から 1本1本
もう何ヶ月かもかかりますけどね
水平線の向こう側を見るのでは足
足のね うん で 足の下や足元を見るべきですと
ではなく すべては当たり前な出来事です
どう？あっけなく終わりました
はい